und wir schalten jetzt direkt weiter
nach Aachen und zwar zu dem für
lützerath zuständigen Polizeipräsidenten
Dirk weinsbach einen schönen guten
Morgen aus Berlin
guten Morgen Frau von Weidenfeld wie ist
sie denn ihre Bilanz was Gewalt
Zusammenstöße Vorankommen der Räumung
angeht
ja wir hatten gestern einen
gewaltausbruches flogen Steine es flogen
Molotow-Cocktails und die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wurden mit Pyrotechnik
beschossen aber Gott sei Dank war das
wohl zeitlich als auch örtlich begrenzt
und jetzt nicht für den Tag und den
Einsatz prägen bisher ihr Polizei Motto
lautete ja Deeskalation durch
Transparenz und Kommunikation würden Sie
sagen ist ihre Strategie insgesamt
aufgegangen trotz der vereinzelten
Gewalt
zumindest Früchte getragen es ist
gelungen kommunikativ über 200 Personen
dazu zu bewegen dieses Gelände
freiwillig zu verlassen es ist auch die
ein oder andere Situation bei den
Räumungen entschärft worden dadurch dass
man miteinander geredet hat also
insofern ist es gut immer auf das Wort
als erstes Einsatzmittel zu setzen und
das werden wir auch weiterhin tun sie
hatten in Form fällt der Räumung
angekündigt die Aktivisten sein eine
Zitat gemischte Szene und dass die
meisten bürgerlich und friedlich sein
und nur eine Minderheit gewaltbereit
haben sie das so gestern also erlebt
die wir können momentan nicht sagen ob
die gewaltbreite Szene Zufluss bekommen
hat aber wir gehen davon aus dass sie
nach wie vor eine Minderheit ist und
sich die Zahl derer die zu
Gewaltstraftaten bereit sind im unteren
zweistelligen Bereich bewegt dann jetzt
zum weiteren vorgeht was passiert heute
und auch in den nächsten Tagen für
Samstag hat sich Greta Thunberg
angekündigt Fridays for future hat sich
angekündigt wie bereiten Sie sich darauf
vor was passiert dann
na das sind unterschiedliche lagen die
Räumungen im der Ortslage lützelrath
gehen jetzt planmäßig voran das heißt
die Räumung der Hallen die gestern
begonnen wird wird heute aller
Voraussicht nach abgeschlossen werden
und dann beginnt man Stück für Stück
weiter dann gegebenenfalls auf das
Wiesengelände an einzelne Baumhäuser und
anderen einzelne Häuser das geht Schritt
für Schritt und mit großer Ruhe und
Besonderheit vielleicht an dieser Stelle
für unsere Zuschauer
sie können gerne noch einen Satz
hinzufügen
was die andere Lage anbelangt die
versammlungslage die für Samstag
vorgesehen ist da sind wir in intensiven
Kooperationsgesprächen mit demjenigen
der die Versammlung organisiert für ein
geeignetes Gelände da stehen wir vor der
Schwierigkeit das wahrscheinlich sehr
viel mehr Menschen kommen werden als
ursprünglich gedacht die
versammlungslage war mit 3000 Personen
angemeldet wir gehen jetzt von
mindestens dem doppelten aus insofern
ist das eine Herausforderung was die
Logistik an Land wir brauchen Parkplätze
wir müssen entsprechende Anfahrtswege
vereinbaren und wir brauchen eine Fläche
auf der sich dann entsprechend viele
Menschen aufhalten können aber diese
Kooperation geführt und wir werden dazu
Lösung kommen dann an dieser Stelle
nochmal zu Erklärung und Einordnung für
die Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer sie
selbst der weinsbach sind grünen
Mitglied und gleichzeitig eben wie
gesagt der Polizeipräsident in Lutzerath
zuständig jetzt für die Räumung in
Aachen und zuständig für die Räumungen
in sie haben gesagt im Vorfeld dass ihre
Kinder zum Beispiel ihre Rolle bei der
Räumung teilweise sehr kritisch wie
gehen Sie mit diesem Zwiespalt um
also ich denke dieses normal in vielen
Familien wird es Diskussionen geben und
da wird es nicht immer einer Meinung
geben also insofern auf der anderen
Seite meine Kinder sind Erwachsenen auch
im Haus sie hatten auch schon gesagt das
sind schwierige Diskussionen die
die ich denke in vielen Bereichen im
Umfeld geführt werden und ja auch die
geführt werden müssen ich nehme an weil
sie gerade schon gesagt hatten im
Vorfeld dass es Ihnen lieber gewesen
wäre wenn die Räumung hätte vermieden
werden können also sie haben durchaus
auch Verständnis für die Protestierenden
ich habe zunächst mal Verständnis für
das Grundanliegen den Klimaschutz und
ich habe auch Verständnis oder Teile die
Sorge dass wir das 1,5 Grad Ziel
verfehlen könnten
auf der anderen Seite das ist kein
Einsatz und deswegen hätte ich mir ein
vermieden
den man freudig angeht der ist mit
besonderen Herausforderungen Risiken
verbunden und insbesondere die Risiken
hätte ich gerne vermieden auch wenn es
bis jetzt nicht zu der ganz krassen
Gewalt in lützerath gekommen ist aber
für ihre Polizistinnen und Polizisten
ist das ja trotzdem keinen Spaziergang
das ist ein sehr komplexes Vorgehen dort
generell gefragt gerade mit Rückblick
auf Silvester haben Sie manchmal das
Gefühl die Polizei muss ausbaden was die
Politik versäumt dass sie also sowas wie
die Prügel Knaben der Nationen sind
dafür hat der Bundespräsident Steinmeier
ja gewarnt
das ist sicherlich manchmal so ob wir
das jetzt hier an dem Ort so beschreiben
weiß ich nicht auf jeden Fall ist es
eine enorme Belastung für die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber sie gehen
das professionell an und in Ruhe und
Besonnenheit und dafür habe ich ihn zu
danken sagt der Polizeipräsident aus
Aachen zuständig für die Räumung in
lützerath weinsbach ich bedanke mich für
das Gespräch